hey everybody its charlie we got to talk
about Walking Dead Thunderdome we got
the greatest of reunions just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet if anything happens to Carol
if she gets a cold we riot so if you
guys are brand new to the channel I do
weekly Walking Dead videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything
they're finally actually doing so the
characters feel like they have active
goals their actions in each of the
episodes are moving them towards that we
have an endpoint we know this war with
the Savior's is coming so now they're
forming alliances everything is
happening all at the same time it's so
great so there is a new round of the
walking dead giveaway going on I'll
explain that at the end of the video
both do top 10 WTF in comic book Easter
eggs MVPs of the episode had to be
Thunderdome Rick Gabriel with that mouth
on them and Daryl who tracked down Carol
for that great reunion in actually
number 10 meet the new group this is not
a group from the comics her name is
Jada's that's the same name as the White
Witch from Chronicles of Narnia make of
that what you will but it's not the
whispers this is an alpha this is a
Magnus group there are a lot of other
groups in The Walking Dead this is march
to war vol 19 where several volumes
after that in the comics there's so much
comic book mature for them to cover the
whispers all those people come way way
later so when we saw these boots we saw
how hardcore they were they had a female
leader like some of the other groups
that we haven't met yet there were a lot
of questions now we know this is
Thunderdome it's like something out of
Mad Max mixed with Lord of the Flies is
so crazy in that weird formal way she
hasn't speaking so I'm really interested
in her character she seems pretty cool
guns give us lots of guns number nine
that opening standoff with the Savior's
this is all part of the Ezekiel plot him
not wanting to get into the fight
Richard being determined to draw them in
so he has another standoff with that
total prick that takes his gun and
Morgan's staff there was a nice callback
for that at the end of the episode
whatever you're holding on to it ain't
there anymore the staff itself is sort
of a metaphor for the way he respects
life he refuses to kill it's literally
been taken from him so now he might have
a reason to kill again that doesn't mean
that he will but just like Carol refuses
to kill there might be that one thing
the one friend that gets hurt that pulls
them back in so if there's anything
there setting up here is it
Ezequiel is probably going to get pushed
over the edge of something happens to
Benjamin that will be the thing that
brings him in because Benjamin like he
says is pretty good with the staff he
disarms the situation but he tells him
not to rush into a fight so that sounds
exactly like what Benjamin is going to
do he's going to throw down
something will happen he'll get himself
killed and that'll be the tipping point
for the kingdom joining the Alliance but
is they're going to pay off anything
they have to let Richard gouge this
dudes eye out he totally deserves it
number eight I hear you're up Bowman
Daryl gets a crossbow back you can just
hear everyone cheering in the background
just the roar of everybody just getting
so excited as he's raising that up in
the air the only thing that would make
that better is if he were wearing a
poncho when that was happening like
here's your crossbow here's your poncho
now hop on the motorcycle and let's kick
some ass so number seven Richards big
plans
Darryl gets to see the clubhouse with
all the secret weapons you see this Katy
backpack and it looks like maybe it
belonged to Richards daughter or
something like that
this is that place where we saw him
break down crying Richards one of my new
favorite characters from the kingdom so
far just because he's so crazy he's so
determined to draw the Savior's into a
fight so they can crush them so Darryl
once he slowly starts finding out what's
going on he starts teasing Carol slowly
gets the idea come on tell me what is
her name in Richard finally explains the
WTF plans at number seven makes Darryl
throw down so he wants to go the
Savior's into a fight you know be they
have this nice mural here of what's
going on in the episode is actually a
truck out of the Smokey and the Bandit
movie but you see the robber robbing the
stagecoach it's a nice visual metaphor
for what Richard wants to do to the
Savior's that are driving by but also a
metaphor for what the Savior's are doing
to everyone else
they're the robbers that are taking from
everyone else but even after they
wrestles themselves bloody he still
tries to convince Darryl that this is
what they need to do it's going to
happen sooner or later we're going to
get another chance but if you were
confused why Darryl was so upset about
Carol it's because she would have been
collateral damage in this first strike
attempt so that's why Darryl won on that
big pair if she starts sneezing if
anything happens to her I'll kill ya
number five hardcore Gabriel at the
stand up
so he's like Rick's hype man he just
like Rick is the person to get you
whatever you need
all about stuff the Garbage Pail Kids
are kind of like an organized more
formal version of the claimers claimed
leave claim Gabriel we claimed all the
stuff from the boat so this is actually
a great art for him you get the big
explainer for what happened in the last
episode why he bailed with all the
supplies he's actually doing a really
good thing it was this really strong art
for his character I'm really happy with
where they've taken him he's had one of
the biggest turnarounds from all the
characters I'm expecting the same thing
for Dwight's character someone who goes
from being human trash to being a really
cool character within the span of a
season so expecting big things for
Gabriel as well as Dwight I know it
always feels like when people like
Gabriel get those really awesome arcs
then they pull the rug out from under us
and kill them but Gabriel is not super
high on the list of people that I think
are going to die this season I feel like
he's got too strong of an arc and just
in the way that Carol did became this
really amazing character they're going
to want to keep him around for a little
bit longer
beyond season 8 though anything goes I
feel like they could get to a solid 10
seasons with the comic book material
that they have at the rate that they're
blowing through it see you guys can let
me know in the comments though it just
feels like any time they give the
secondary characters like that are
really amazing or something really bad
is on the horizon so as long as he
doesn't get too full of himself or get
too heroic I feel like he'll be okay
but this is so much fun number four rick
has to enter Thunderdome and defeat the
mouth of Sauron Walker to win them an
alliance with this new group if you
don't know who that is there was this
big deleted scene from The Return of the
King where there was this creature that
was made to look like this Walker who
became a mouthpiece for Sauron to speak
through literally speak through so Rick
wins Thunderdome cuts his hand in the
process he better get that cleaned up
pretty fast he hurts his hand more than
anything I feel like that's the Hat tip
for what happens to him in the comics
the thing that they're probably never
going to do on the TV show but number
three Rick makes the deal with Jada
there was that funny moment where she
gags it the idea of shaking his bloody
hand is hardcore she is they gave them
so much set up like oh my god it's
another version of Carol the Terminator
this is going to be so much fun to see
her with all the guns they're going to
get for them but they had that funny
haggling scene where they're like okay
we'll give you a third of the stuff we
stole she explains the boat we were
waiting for a long time for someone to
go get that stuff we don't do that we
actually just takes
from people we don't go out and find
stuff ourselves so she seems weirdly
complicated and it's super interesting I
can't wait to see more of her character
but as much as he seemed is pressed with
the idea of Gabriel speech the way he
talked rigged up the way he proved
himself I think it's just the idea of
all the stuff that they'll get to take
from the Savior's that's the reason
they're joining the Alliance like oh
crap we're going to get a ton of stuff
if we take down this other group there's
also a big deep cut for way back in
season 3 Michonne's rainbow cat if you
don't remember that Rick isn't that
trash cat here this is replace the ones
that you lost I believe that is an
easter egg for the rainbow cat but you
guys can let me know in the comments it
was from like a really young choral side
trip to the king county cafe where she
busts in there's all these walkers in
there and she comes out with this
rainbow cat just couldn't leave this
behind it's just too damn beautiful
number two it is the big hat tip for
Oceanside you saw how conveniently they
set that up at the end of the episode
okay we need a lot of guns Tara you been
out further than any of us why don't you
tell us where not to go and she has that
funny look on her face like oh I got I
got an idea I know where to go there's
another group led by a female as well
maybe they'll have something in common
with this other female led group so
whether or not the actual Oceanside
people come to help them out physically
they'll at least get most of the guns
that they need but you can see how
they're setting things up it's not going
to be super easy like 1 2 3 we have all
the people all the guns let's move on
them now so the other thing is they need
to pay off from the Terra episode that's
really what this was it was the payoff
from the Terra episode is the key card
which I think the biggest theory right
now probably the best theory is that
that is how they open the doors at the
satellite station so hopefully we'll
find out about that either next week or
the week after because next week seems
like a really Savior's heavy episode so
we'll touch base with all the people we
haven't seen since the show's comeback
but really like the number one moment
has to be that Carol Daryl reunion at
the end of the episode so cry worthy
such a great fake out reveal to where
they come up with the Cobblers they're
like hey you know we just wanted to
check on you they go away knock again at
the door Carol's like ah god damn it
people bothering me and it's Daryl they
both break down crying the whole thing
here is just delaying the inevitable
Carol will find out about Abraham and
Glen eventually like you saw her like
down cry if anything happened to them I
don't know what I would do her soul
would die she would be Terminator Carol
full on 100% no going back so the real
question out is is she going to find out
from someone else and that's what's
going to bring her into the fight or is
it going to be like the Benjamin thing
where this innocent person that she kind
of cares about a little bit that Ezekiel
really cares about might end up dying in
that brings them in either way we had a
really great reunion moment just letting
us know that Carol will eventually come
back but it's going to take some big WTF
moments before she does either she's
going to find out about her friend or a
new friend is going to have to die so
let me know in the comments which you
think it's going to be what's going to
happen tomorrow's I have some new
spider-man homecoming to pose there's
some more Marvel and DC but there is a
new round of the walking dead giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Blake Johnson please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details where
you wait for that you can click here for
a brand new game of Thrones and you can
click here for all my Walking Dead
videos thank you so much for watching
everyone let's high five I'll see you in
the next video